if it wasn't weird enough that in 2020
you couldn't leave the house
and everyone you knew was dressed as a
heart surgeon accidentally trips
on a metal plate falls to the ground
dropping the heart
then the ever-changing english language
was getting even
weirder thanks to the culture wars
and it wasn't just ted talks changing
the word women
to womackson which i still can't say
the term turf was making deeper inroads
into the global lexicon turf stands for
trans-exclusionary radical feminist and
they're awful don't confuse it with wtf
now the feminists that believe that your
gender is based on whether you've got
dangly bits or not
get your hand off my penis rather than
which dangly bit
you identify with dangly part
i'm still not sure if it's a compliment
or an insult
depends on your perspective also not
going away is this business with
people's pronouns
the former leader of the labour party in
the uk
jeremy corbyn shared his pronouns
here he is how are you doing we're back
and we're ready for it all over again
and what do you think
they are the beard is a clue
we're back oh yeah and uh vice
president-elect
carmela harris has her pronouns on
twitter too
again you won't be surprised what they
are
[Music]
oh yeah and the un has now decided that
the terms
husband and wife are politically
incorrect
it's not funny john and you know it's
been coming for a long time
my dad is going to be furious he's now
an
ex-ex-husband divorced
stop laughing even the dictionary is
joining in
merriam-webster had to change its
definition of racism
after a student emailed to say that it
didn't reflect her life
or systemic oppression that she'd
experienced
i emailed them to ask if they'd changed
the definition of snowflake
you've got mayo but i didn't hear back
and merriam-webster totally backed up
its social justice warrior credentials
after it defined the term sexual
preference as
being offensive senator maisie hirono
claimed that sexual preference is an
offensive
and outdated term sexual orientation is
a key part
of a person's identity you just can't
help who you fall in love with
all of this starts to make sense when
you see that some university
wasted some of its funding to conclude
that full stops are offensive to
[Music]
millennials
dr lauren fontaine of leyden university
conducted research that found that
millennials and gen zias so rarely use
punctuation when they message each other
that when they receive
a message with a full stop in it it can
be seen as intimidating
and a sign of passive aggression well
gen zeus
how do you like
[Music]
you